back in may of 2007 uh this is almost 14
years ago my gosh
time is flying i posted a series of
blogs on my my personal
uh blog at calacanis.com and the first
one
was i would pay for twitter.com
literally 14 years ago i said i would
pay for this
but i was pro proposing in that blog
post 100 year
premium offering three times what
they're charging for this
uh twitter blue product this rumored
twitter blue product
and that it would give you a dedicated
server independent
and would um be faster some more
features and better speed
and this was because there was a really
acute problem the early days of twitter
it would take a long time to post your
message and it was slow and it crashed
a year later in may of 2008 i posted
twitter pro one year later same request
take my money for less downtime
and here's the quote i still think
there's a huge market perhaps one to
five percent of twitter base
uh that would pay for a professional
account if one percent of 10 million
users because that's how many they had
at the time
would pay 20 a month or 250 a year
you're looking at a hundred thousand
paid
users at 250 a year each that's 25
million in
revenue probably too high of a number uh
in terms of the price
per user and obviously too low of a
number in terms of where they actually
wound up
uh in q1 twitter had 199 million
monetizable daily active users yes so
mdau is monetizable daily active users
most people say daily activities i think
what they're doing here twitter when
they
say monetizable daily active users is
taking out bots and people maybe who
would never pay if one to five percent
of those paid
250 a year that would be 2 million to 10
million users and that would be 500
million to 2.5 billion a year
and so that would be approximately you
know at five percent
250 a year that would be 67 of their
2020 revenue
now that price is too high that might
work actually
that would be cheap for professional
accounts so if you were a journalist
if you were a ceo if you had a corporate
account
those numbers actually would be quite
reasonable because people already pay
for things like buffer where they pay
for analytical tools etc
and they obviously have people on staff
who are getting paid
well to to staff their twitter accounts
so 250 a year for a professional twitter
account is not
that big of a deal if one to five
percent of those same users
on twitter uh paid this you know alleged
299 price 36
a year that'd be 72 million to 360
million a year
what's interesting about that number is
it would be 100 profit
i mean you might have some fees if they
allowed it through the app store and
gave a 30
cut to uh somebody like apple or google
but essentially you're you're talking
about hundreds of millions of dollars
and it would probably become 10 uh
20 of their revenue of course you lose
some ads on the margins
but the truth is twitter has been known
to not
show ads to the most important accounts
in other words if you've got
over 100 000 followers you're probably
gonna not see
so many ads or at least that's the rumor
in january of 2008 i gave twitter or i
speculated this is before twitter had
revenue turned on that they would have
three
wildly lucrative businesses in feed
advertising which
is obviously how they generate revenue
today subscriptions and
sms advertising because at the time sms
was a big piece of the twitter
experience in fact twitter
started as an sms service most people
don't know that obviously
that's been deprecated so two out of
three ain't bad um it only took him 13
years but here we are
back in march of 2009 i asked
twitter if they would take 250 000 from
me it was a sincere offer by the way
to become a default user and that would
make me featured and i thought it would
result in five or ten thousand
people following an account today and i
had a product called mahalo answers at
the time which was kind of like quora
but with a virtual currency in it i kid
you not it had mahalo dollars where
people would
get these dollars and then they could
cash them out for uh other products and
even gift cards it was
you know before cryptocurrency we had a
concept of virtual currencies
that was it was a precursor and i owned
at questions and add answers so i was
like oh if we get at questions we could
do
uh we could promote that product or
service i should have kept that going
because
it obviously uh is valuable and here are
some quotes from that article of course
i was only half
bluffing with this move i was 90 sure
twitter wouldn't take my money
and i wouldn't have to pony up the 250
000 check however if they did call my
bluff
and cashed it the 250 i actually would
have gotten what i wanted two to ten
million twitter followers and the
ability to drive one to two million
visits to mahalo a month
from twitter because at the time that
would be you know an expected click rate
you know five ten
twenty percent that's obviously changed
dramatically as uh the number of debt
accounts on twitter has increased
uh my plan was to post the top five most
absolutely fascinating questions a day
from mahalo answers
uh and you know do that to the questions
account which i still own to this day
the point is that twitter has the
ability to unleash a direct marketing
business
the likes of which the world has never
seen i predict they will
and when they do they will make the
twitter naysayers look like the donkeys
they really are
note do you ever notice the folks who
have the most to say about making money
are the ones who've
never made any exactly wow i used to be
a little spicy in my writing there
full contact blogging twitter is a giant
open email box
that we all hang out in every day the
power of twitter is yet to be fully
understood
in the same way email and the web
weren't fully understood that's actually
pretty impressive and i give myself some
credit for that
and that's a nice metaphor actually the
open email box